let me jump to these stories here the
first from Daily Mail quote use
low-yield nuclear weapons Russia
appointed official inkerson calls for
tough action from Moscow and urges the
country defense minister Sergey shoigu
to shoot himself amid frustration at
Ukrainian fight back we also have this
story
from Reuters katarov says Russia should
use low-yield nuclear weapon so uh
they're outright saying use the nukes
this is interesting because I feel like
nuclear war man if there's anything that
would happen that would make a great
reset happen it would be nuclear bombs
dropping but the question is
is this you know what's happening in
Ukraine going to affect the entire
planet or is it going to stay Regional
is it going to become something that
forces the West to get involved or does
Ukraine just get you know win or lose I
don't know when nukes come into play I
don't see how the whole world doesn't
get involved
I mean I guess one thing that does make
me nervous is where's China and all this
when the nukes start flying what does
China do well sit back and laugh well
yeah they could I guess and just watch
us commit suicide Annex is a huge part
of Eastern Russia yeah you know watch
out for that well Kissinger had some
interesting comments about China and how
they're looking at everything that's
happening right now we also have to
understand that Ukraine and China were
very big trading partners and there's a
lot of economic interests that the
Chinese have inside of Ukraine so this
could be one reason why they kind of
stepped back a little bit but according
to Henry Kissinger the Chinese gave the
Russians a blank check when it came to
um this this conflict right now I'm not
really seeing it uh but I I think it's
it's in their interest for themselves to
be like you know what we're just going
to take a step back as you two guys beat
each other up and we're going to rise as
as a potential superpower or try to rise
as a potential superpower well that's
the Art of War right never interrupt
your enemies when they're destroying
each other yes and there's been a lot of
historical tensions between Russia and
China they have started to work closer
together especially with the United
States becoming more aggressive against
both of them they started to share a lot
of military secrecy they started to
build a lot of military infrastructure
together but historically they've been
at odds even when it comes to specific
territory that they were were
threatening each other with just a few
decades ago
The Intercept report that I saw earlier
I think uh Michael Tracy was tweeting
about it I mean that was just a kick in
the balls what it was that the US is
operating officially U.S Special
Operations and intelligence are
operating in Ukraine so like that's it
they they this is the game they play the
US and NATO they didn't come out
outright and say we're going to engage
in war with Russia they they dropped
news periodically first it was like well
some people volunteered just what
happens to their Americans then it's
well we're giving weapons to you know
Poland and it's being delivered to
Ukraine but it's not us and then the U.S
Intel U.S intelligence helped Ukraine
blow up the Russian Black Sea Fleet
Flagship and then said oh well we didn't
tell them to do that
now the U.S is saying well yeah we we do
have special operations on the ground
that are ours and our intelligence has
been operating there I'm gonna tell you
this they're they're blaming Ukraine for
the assassination of uh Dugan's daughter
yeah
how long give it a week two weeks a
month before they're like oh yeah we
actually ordered that or at first
they're going to say we gave them the
information on where Dugan would be but
we didn't know that would happen and
then a month that's gonna be like yeah
it was us so so basically what the
United States is doing is handing
someone a gun and saying we're going to
point it exactly where you're going to
kill this opponent and the only thing
they're they're not doing is pulling the
trigger that's not sure anymore
but some people as as you know you would
argue they're doing even more than just
pulling the trigger
deniability no no here's what it is all
right all right so Joel you're you're
fighting with your neighbor and so I'm
like all right here's what we're gonna
do I'm gonna give you this uh glass
bottle all right now you're gonna you
got you got that but uh but you know
what uh actually Luke used to work for
me Luke you go do it that's basically
what it is yeah it starts with people
are like they used to be soldiers for
this Army but now it's just their choice
to go there right right right and they
and then they have weapons that get
supplied by NATO and then eventually
they're just like yeah they're paying us
so yeah we're involved at what point
does everyone figure out that just you
know when do we eliminate the middleman
and just go direct at each other I
imagine I'm saying you know look just
I mean like if Joe Biden wants my
respect he'll come out and be like my
fellow Americans
of course we're at war with Russia what
he's stupid you don't think U.S boots on
the ground funding supplies intelligence
and War you think that does not imply
that we are fighting right we thinking
yeah but these you know I think what you
get from Twitter and from the media is
you can really see these like psychotic
fascist journalists will say whatever to
keep regular people trapped in the dark
right they'll call you fake news they'll
lie they'll push conspiracy theories and
then claim it's you doing that
projection is the only thing they have
and the best part is they accuse
everyone else of projecting when it's
quite literally then projected yeah
they're the fascists supporting the
machine and supporting the war now we're
facing the prospect of uh getting hit by
a nuke so I guess you know for uh for
you guys have you guys bought your
potassium iodide yet I had mine for many
years ago as I was warning about this on
my YouTube channel saying hey we're
headed towards a conflict with Russia
like like 10 years ago I was making
videos about this I was like
geopolitically everything's aligning
everything's shaping up as of course
this is not the first proxy war that
happened between in the East and the
West we look at Syria we look at Libya
we look at Afghanistan in the 1980s the
United States and the Russians have
always been at odds with each other
always financing the enemy of the enemy
and this is nothing new but now I think
we have really escalated it to a
dangerous situation that implicates
everyone in it including everyone that's
not even fighting innocent human beings
or being affected by this in more ways
than one not just financially but what
about what about other countries I mean
turkey military Power Nuclear superpower
they're a Russian neighbor they I mean
Russia they're a NATO member yeah and
they're in NATO which is very strange
but Russia has no Mediterranean access
with or without the annexation they're
trying to approve without turkey so
they're they have to be allies for this
war to resolve in Russia's favor
but they're in NATO what the hell's
going on they have nuclear weapons what
the hell is going on oh it's simple
Klaus Schwab had a meeting with Putin
and Biden and said we need to grid reset
everything let's pretend to have a war
and they're like okay that'll give us an
excuse to launch the nukes and then I'm
kidding by the way but hey man I I can
only say that cloud Schwab is probably
sitting back being like this is war is
very good
yeah this wolf is inevitable we need
order
order
well and how much of this too is driven
just by the like the military industry I
mean it have we gotten to the point
where just we always need some kind of a
war we had Iraq we had Afghanistan we
got out of Afghanistan now it's Russia
after Russia is it going to be something
else I mean is it just a continual war
machine where we're feeding this beast
that's what Eisenhower told us it was
going to be and after Vietnam in the
early 70s they I mean there was just a
slew of like military interactions I'm
very in the dark about it's just they
they're so obfuscated in the in the
Balkans uh in like obviously Serbia
Kosovo with like in the Clinton years I
remember hearing about Serbia and Kosovo
and Bosnia like there was just bombs
going over I never knew what was what
who was who I just knew that we were
involved in all this death
um
yeah I think without without conflict
and places to blow up bombs with with
some sort of reason whether it's Faker
or real than the military-industrial
complex will cease to function yes
sometimes I wonder if all this money is
being sent to Ukraine and is kind of
like to help replace the Lost revenue
from leaving Afghanistan in the Middle
East like 100 billion dollars yeah on
the books that have been sent over there
in the middle of the economic recession
they've set 100 billion dollars to some
country that we're not even allies with
and then what happens they buy weapons
from who
God knows the Chinese the Russians I
don't know where they're going away from
yeah and they're buying you know from us
it's our own money being given right
back to us there's a reason there's a
saying that war is a racket because it
is and the only winners of the war are
the people who finance uh the wars the
people who of course bankroll the sides
and sell the arms and the weapons
everyone else loses there's no real
winners in war military people who
profit off of it military-industrial
complex grifting yeah for them it's like
we need to justify why we need more
weapons let's get mad at somebody and
claim they're bad and then go fight them
yeah well there's more pigs right well
first uh the recent U.S policy is hey
we're going to give these guys a bunch
of weapons and then a couple years later
these are the bad guys we gotta fight
these guys with all these weapons Saddam
Hussein he has he has chemical weapons
that we gave him to fight the Iranians
the the syrians they have all these
weapons they have all these Humvees and
trucks with American businesses on the
side of them we gotta go fight them
they're gonna attack and kill us the
Libyan and you know Gaddafi he's a very
bad guy we sold them a bunch of weapons
but he's a bad guy now we got to take
him out because he wants to do a gold
dinar so there it goes on and on and on
I could never stop the tally about it
yeah we gotta fight we gotta fight the
Russians in Afghanistan we got to give
them all the all the weapons oh no the
Taliban no they're bad now yeah we gotta
go fight them I tweeted out a video of
this guy who went to Afghanistan
recently this video on YouTube is called
tourism and Taliban controlled
Afghanistan he went he interviewed
Taliban he's like what do you think of
Joe Biden and the big the older Taliban
member who's doing the speaking was like
we are Joe Biden did a great job by
leaving we hope he never comes back you
can see he left us all this equipment
that the Taliban is driving around on
right now we're very grateful for Joe
Biden oh yeah they love him he's got a
98 approval rating over there they call
it Independence Day the day 9 11 when we
pull when we say really the Italian
calls it Independence Day well when we
surrender when we surround a day that we
surrendered at Taliban yeah wow
thanks Joe Biden yeah we just well nine
trillion dollars making sure that we get
you know we replace the Taliban with the
Taliban the money well spent thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there